Film Courage: So let’s say someone has made
a bold move come from wherever to Los Angeles
or New York (one of these major cities) and
they’ve been here several years and now
they’re in a new kind of rut, a new kind
of comfort zone….
“Yeah, I’m going out.
I’m submitting [fill in the blank of whatever]
but it’s habit-driven and it’s not really
going anywhere.”
But hey, they are here in this big city and
are supposedly working, they are supposedly
getting stuff out there, how do you shake
that up?
And I know I’m being a little bit vague.
Gary W. Goldstein: It’s not vague.
Film Courage: But let’s just say they are
here.
Gary W. Goldstein: If you want to play tennis,
find yourself a pro.
That’s the game.
That’s how you improve.
The problem with most creatives, they comes
to LA, the come to New York and what do they
do?
Most of them learn bad habits, why?
Because they are learning, mimicking like
people around them.
I’m an actor, I’m following what other
actors are doing.
I’m asking them, I’m learning from them,
yet they are not at the top of the totem.
Same with writers, same with producers, it
doesn’t matter.
Human beings.
Writers (as one example), I get query letters
every day, blind query letters.
“Dear So and So…”
It could be my name, it could be ‘creative
executive,’ it could be my name misspelled,
it could be anything.
“Dear So and So…”
Log line, short description, “Can I send
a script?
I’ll sign a release.”
Signed…John.
That’s what I get repeatedly all day long
in my inbox.
There is not one lick of research.
There is not one lick of anything personal,
like why is this the writer (the only writer)
who could have written this story?
Why was it so compelling that they chose this
out of all the stories in one’s imagination?
Why did they choose to send it to me?
Now I don’t want to receive the agony and
the ecstasy as a letter but something…a
drop, a kernel, something that stands out
and makes me think.
Makes me react.
Makes me wonder about this.
But they don’t.
I can promise you not even 1% do what I’m
describing.
So this is what writers learn from other writers
and the actors learning from other actors,
etc.
They learn the habitual tried-and-true, day-to-day
protocol which is usually very unsuccessful.
The ROI (the return-on-investment) in sending
blind query blind query letters has got to
be horribly frustrating?
If you’re a business, you’d be bankrupt.
So why do it?
Because this is what other people are doing.
You need to associate with more successful
people and you need to think about it differently.
If you were a fashion designer and you took
that approach, you focus on your craft, focus
on your craft, focus on your craft and you
sent out letters saying “Here’s my designs.
Aren’t I great!”
You’d never have a brand.
You have to think in terms of business.
You have to think in terms of ‘What more
can I do that others aren’t doing?’
As opposed to ‘What they are doing.
How do I stand out?’
Separating yourself out from the herd is definitely
the name of the game and anyone who has invested
that blood, sweat and tears, that sort of
soul equity of investing all of that time
writing 120 or 110 pages (whatever) of story
and rewriting it until it is just so.
But they want to share their wares with the
world.
Now they’re so proud of this.
They should invest a like amount of time figuring
out how to market and how to be a business
person and how to reach out to people and
how to do things differently than all of their
peers.
Like that’s a great measurement.
Am I doing what everyone else is doing or
am I being somehow, putting myself out into
the world and speaking of myself to the right
people in ways that matter?
Film Courage: You mentioned fashion and it
had me thinking of [designer] Diane von Furstenberg
and her wrap dress and how it was this dress
that no one had ever really seen before and
it fit every body type.
It made every body type look good and so you
are talking about fashion and it made me think
of that.
Gary W. Goldstein: How many times do we see
artists like Steve Jobs, Johnny Cash, Lady
Gaga…I mean there’s a million ways to
stand out.